hi everybody I'm Larry herb xbox live's
Major Nelson twitter is a massive part
of everyday life for me in fact I was
one of the first 100 people to be on
Twitter it's the first thing I fire up
every morning so I can see what the
community is talking about now if you
follow me you know it's where i post
news every day twitter has become a
natural outlet for community
conversations during major TV shows and
live events in fact I'm told by my
friends at Twitter that they see over
255 million users every month and 500
million tweets per day so when I heard
Xbox was working with Twitter to build
an experience for Xbox one I wanted to
share with you what the teams are
working on the first place you'll see
Twitter on Xbox one is in the one guy
where a custom twitter experience is
embedded directly into the xbox one
program guide we're also bringing a new
trending section 21 guide that will
display the TV shows and movies that
people are tweeting about including
their trending hashtags for example if
it's Monday night then Fox's 24 live
another day is on and trending you are
to give Jack Bauer whatever he needs
Plus silence the second place you can
experience twitter is in the TV mini
guide by pressing the View button on the
controller in the mini-guide you can see
the conversation that's happening on
Twitter through the stream that includes
relevant hashtags for each show the
official Twitter handles and tweets from
the cast and crew from within the tweet
stream you can favorite and retweet
directly from your Twitter account
however you don't need to be logged in
with your Twitter credentials to view
others tweets we can't wait to bring the
new Twitter experience to you later this
year thanks for watching